ludovic de l'aer expert en communication
bonsoir ludovic de la recherche
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france avant les chefs de partis réunis
ce soir pour décider de la tenue d'un
second tour
on voit évidemment et on comprend la
volonté de dialogue du gouvernement
c'est un choix politique avant tout
c'est un choix politique qui c'est un
choix aussi de de communication me
semble-t-il stéphanie est ce que bonsoir
d'abord merci de m'inviter
on est dans un procès c'est une
ritournelle aujourd'hui qui peut acter
de la part de notre chef de l'état
emmanuel macron qui souhaitent se
déresponsabiliser on a plusieurs sorties
de sa part où il affirme ce soit des
fausses vérités soient carrément des
mensonges ou se positionne en spectateur
remettant tout ça sans gouvernement
et là il tenterait en plus de tout
remettre sur les parlementaires qu'ils
devraient voter oui ou non pour ce
second tour
sans information et sans respect de deux
critères qui semble assez non essentiels
tout d'abord le premier qui est évident
qui est salutaire pour ne pas reproduire
les graves erreurs qu'ils ont commises
en organisant le premier tour il faut
oublier que ce premier tour a été décidé
seul par emmanuel macron et et son
gouvernement sans en demander au
préalable l'avis du parlement
et on connaît les conséquences et ses
conséquences et ses responsabilités
aujourd'hui ils essayent de le partager
et de demander au parlement de
l'endosser ce qui est évidemment
extrêmement compliqué parce que en plus
mécaniquement en termes de communication
ça permettrait de leur faire endosser
aussi le premier tour car après tout
s'ils votent pour un second tour
on pourrait suspecter qu'ils auraient
voté aussi prend un premier tour et ce
bilan du premier tour il est quand même
catastrophique donc il faut mettre aussi
des mots sur les sur les choses parce
que on a eu beaucoup d'informations et
de fausses vérités qu'on circule et le
premier tour par exemple esmery hallon
dans les hauts de france
c'est cyril boulanger 37 ans qui est
mort le 5 avril l'udc au vide après
avoir voté et être assesseurs et ceci
christophe batteur vasseur pardon 51 ans
premier adjoint qui est mort le 28 ans
voilà ça ce sont des noms concrets et
des faits concrets sur la responsabilité
du premier tour est ce qu'on doit
reproduire la même chose pour lui pour
le second tour il tente de se
déresponsabiliser à nouveau comme il le
fait sur l'ensemble des des éléments de
cette crise
que vive depuis le départ on a lu ici ou
là plusieurs fois justement que le
gouvernement n'avait pas pris seul cette
responsabilité qu'ont contraire et mâcon
n'était pas spécialement chaud pour
organiser ce premier tour mais qu'il a
fait sous la pression notamment de
l'opposition vous n'y croyez pas ah
voilà ce fossile a convié un petit peu
partout depuis ce premier tour quand
même sessegnon pour le moment autant de
communication et manu acron chaque fois
qu'il a pu imputer la responsabilité
clairement à quelqu'un il l'a fait là ça
a été dit à demi-mot c'était
effectivement écrit en disant que ça
aurait pu être éventuellement externe
terrain en attendant on est en crise il
a voulu les pleins pouvoirs et c'est le
chef de l'état donc c'est lui qui décide
soyons clairs il n'a pas consulté le
parlement il n'a pas consulté
officiellement l'opposition cirque il
n'y a pas eu de séance au parlement pour
le premier tour et là ils veulent en
faire une sur le second tour on peut
comprendre les réticences parce que il
faut deux points évidemment le premier
et sanitaires comme je vous le disais
mais le deuxième il est aussi
démocratique parce que pourquoi
organiser un second tour
il veut absolument garantir un temps de
campagne une campagne et une élection
c'est un moment pour convaincre
c'est un moment pour un débat d'idées
pour exposer des projets et convaincre
sur la pertinence de ces projets il ne
faut pas croire à cette mécanique en
marche qui croit qu'une élection ça
n'est qu'un exercice comptable et bien
non la démocratie ça n'est pas ça donc
il faut pouvoir garantir ces deux points
là et aujourd'hui on a un conseil
scientifique qui n'a pas avalisé qui n'a
pas donné son accord à ce à la tenue de
ce second tour
il n'a pas non plus c'est pas pu non
plus prononcée contre il a fait une
réponse un peu sibylline est évasive
donc donc il faut que emmanuel macron
s'ils souhaitent un deuxième tour prenne
ses responsabilités et l'imposent
ou alors en conscience le décale
effectivement signés soit à la rentrée
ce qu'en 2021
aujourd'hui on le voit le gouvernement
et notamment le chef de l'état sont en
grande difficulté
à quoi doit-on s'apprend s'attendre on a
parlé à un temps du remplacement du
premier ministre
marine le pen elle demande la
dissolution de l'assemblée quelles sont
les alternatives les plus crédibles
selon vous ce qu'est ce qui est évident
c'est ce qui se dit et je ne vais pas
dévoiler un secret de polichinelle est
ce qu'il travaille à un gouvernement
d'union nationale nationale c'est à dire
que sur cette toujours cette séquence
politique de déresponsabilisation
il semblerait qu emmanuel macron
voudrait s'acheter une virginité avec un
gouvernement c'est-à-dire que emmanuel
philippe partirait avec l'eau du bain
on lui mettrait entre guillemets un tout
sur le dos pardonnez moi ces mots mais
c'est c'est la séquence sur lesquels on
est en train de se préparer pour réunir
un un gouvernement qui serait autour de
lui grand chef vainqueur seul capable de
rassembler il décale déjà certains
députés pour ce revers d'hier et sert
socialiser un peu donc il serait il sert
peint de rose rouge et de vert grâce à
ce nouveau mouvement au sein de
l'assemblée qui n'est pas un mouvement
de contestation vous faut pas non plus
nous prendre pour des idiots
et puis surtout en continuant de
maintenir le parlement dans un rôle qui
n'est pas celui du parlement titah
consulter le parlement il aurait fallu
les écouter plutôt le parlement il ya
quand même des gens qui travaillent
il ya un plan de déconfinement qui a été
proposé il a été repoussé de la main et
se confrontent en permanence à un visage
glacée de l'exécutif qui reste dans sa
propre litani et c'est encore une fois
une vision idéologique de la politique
le parlement n'est pas une chambre
comptable des bras levés en cadence non
ce n'est pas ça la démocratie ça n'est
pas ça le parlement donc il en train de
se préparer à un gouvernement d'union et
on peut très bien imaginer oui derrière
que fort de ce gouvernement d'union il
pourrait avoir comme velléités de
dissoudre
bon ça nous donnerait un élément concret
c'est qu'on aurait un chef de l'état
totalement hors sol étant donné
aujourd'hui
la cote de popularité du mouvement en
marche au sein de la population
française est dédié des citoyens qui
voient ce qui se passe et qui entendent
depuis le départ et encore une fois
prendre des décisions il faut pouvoir le
faire avec des informations fiables et
depuis le début de cette crise s'il ya
bien un marqueur clair c'est que les
fausses vérités ont circulé sait qu'on a
un exécutif qui nous a menti cacher des
choses
très rapidement vous savez on a comme
aujourd'hui on a des informations
concrètes qui tombe le 28 février entre
le 28 février et le 6 mars le taux de
contamination en france a progressé de
5000% de 5000% c'est absolument énorme
je suis ma ou pardonnez moi je me coupe
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya d'autres
invités derrière et merci en tout cas on
a compris en substance votre analyse
ludovic de l'air jeu pardonnez moi de
vous avoir coupé merci à vous d'avoir
été avec nous et